the so-called pace line
resembled a war zone cars were hijacked
crashed into the gates that keep
communities apart and torched
the scenes that we saw were absolutely
disgraceful
in terms of the serious criminal acts
that were being carried out
and the violent disorder that was taking
place
and it needs to be condemned in the
strongest possible terms
earlier teenagers had petrol bombed a
bus
risking the lives of the driver and
passengers
with the brexit border in the irish sea
in flaming tension in loyalist areas
the northern ireland secretary returned
to belfast i'll be the first to
acknowledge over the first few months
this year there are real issues around
how the protocol has landed for people
both as consumers
and those in the unionist loyalist
community that sense of identity
the way to deal with these things is
through a diplomatic democratic
political process
there is no legitimization or excuse for
taking to violence to deal with any of
these issues
under pressure to help restore calm
stormont was recalled from its easter
recess
the first minister who's ill
participating virtually
the harm to northern ireland's image and
this our centenary year
has taken us backwards and no brick
no bottle no petrol bomb thrown has
achieved or can
ever achieve anything but destruction
harm and fear as political leaders we
must stand united and appealing to all
concerned
to refrain from further threats or use
of violence
it's not right it's dangerous it's
unacceptable
and it is a miracle that as we stand
here today that no one
has been killed
this trouble started when sinn fein
escaped prosecution
for alleged breaches of covert
regulations at an ira
funeral some of those engaged in the
rioting are in their early teens
i mean the one thing i won't do is sit
back and allow people to use young
people who's counting for her
billy hutchinson is a former loyalist
paramilitary
he rejects claims the main groups are
orchestrating this
you know as well as i do necessary we've
always looked for buggy men
i think what we need to be looking for
is the people who make peace
uh and those people including the
foreign militaries
are still signed up their peace process
there's a battle going on for the heart
and mind of loyalism
and as always sinister elements are
seeking to exploit that for criminal
purposes
that makes it difficult to be specific
about what's causing the outbreak of
violence
at flash points like this one it's even
more difficult to contain it
when rioters are too young to have
experienced life before peace here
david blevins sky news in belfast